brinker bout I think you probably are
too probably the most provocative title
we have three French I'm going to tell
you all about she went to yell and yell
and yell he'll tell us about okay can
everybody hear me yes um could you close
the doors so I'm a professor zoom
thought that I should maybe give a few
minutes about how I became a scientist
so this morning at nine-thirty I through
some slides together to let you know how
that happened and so I pulled up this is
a lecture I gave in 2011 I pulled the
slides from this lecture and just to let
you know what I really work on so I
don't work on poop poop is only a hobby
for me what I what I really work on are
these factories that that cells have
that make proteins and they're called
ribosomes and I pioneered the study of
ribosomes and how they're made in the
cell nucleus and I now work on the human
diseases of making ribosomes to the
point where there are patients father's
contacting me for help throughout the
world so that's what I really do for a
living I'm a scientist because my father
is a scientist he was the most profound
influence on me this is my father and
out of bizarre ago when he was about the
same age I am now he's now 91 years old
he was a scientist he retired to at age
87 okay was fully funded by the national
institutes of health till then he hasn't
had an interesting life he was born in
Italy in 1925 and during world war two
was a partisan
so he slept on straw for two years was
the hut was a leader of a band of 80
people whose job it was to thwart the
Germans in Italy in the 1940s he
immigrated to the United States in 1953
to be a scientist and serves and still
serves as an inspiration for me in my
life he believed that both his daughters
could be anything they wanted to be so
as you heard from curt i'm yael and yell
and yell and yell okay i came here in
1976 and never left this is kind of a
boring CVL Yale yeah yeah yeah yeah you
get that yet the idea and the hence the
Bulldog I did what you're not supposed
to do and I paid some prices along the
way for doing this part of the reason I
stayed here so long is that I married
one of my classmates in medical school
this is Peter Glaser who's also a
physician scientist and as a is the
chair of therapeutic radiology at the
Medical School and as you can see we
were both much younger than my face some
challenges along the way and I'm putting
this in for the kids in the audience so
this is my third grade report card and
you can see that my teacher the time
said that my work was satisfactory that
I must work on improving my disposition
that I was moody I responded poorly to
constructive criticism and I frequently
rebelled if not given her own way I
would say this last part is still true
but I had a teacher in high school this
was my art teacher and this is too long
to read so I just exhibit I had an art
teacher and you must keep in mind that I
have no talent in art at all I'm like
auntie talented in art but he saw
something in me that would bode me well
in my future career choice where he
wrote a Susan never seems fearful of
even the most difficult of tasks is
important to be undaunted in life where
other students her age would hedge and
back away student died Susan dives in
meeting each challenge head-on to see
such enthusiasm and eagerness and a
student of her age is truly inspiring so
there you go and let's do you think that
my life has been easy being a woman in
science in the 21st century is quite a
challenge and so I've come up with a
series of life lessons that you may or
may not
up for yourselves I've chosen work as my
passion I fully believe in persevering
and persisting that intelligence is
important but it's not the most
important thing being persistent is the
most important thing and I make an
absolute habit of ignoring the people
who tell me I can't do what I want to do
you should surround yourself with people
who are smarter than you I'm always very
happy when one of my students is smarter
than me and I hope that they all are I
get lots of advice from people but then
I make my own decisions I always try to
move forward I try not to have any guilt
I don't stew and I don't ruminate it's
not useful and then also I have a sense
of humor as you might be able to tell
from the title of this talk which is the
promise of poop and I'm using the word
poop to represent feces and unless do
you think I thought of this title at a
full disclosure I stole the title from
the science magazine who wrote this
article in 2013 and the article is about
fecal transplants and that's what would
be talking about today and how they
service hope for treating many diseases
and we're really going to focus on only
one disease today and that is an
infection called Clostridium difficile
otherwise known as c diff for which
fecal transplants have really given hope
to people and I want to pose a question
before I launch into the arguments how
many organisms is this so this organism
happens to be my son who's a basketball
player as you can see is this one
organism or is it 90 trillion organisms
it's 90 trillion organisms and so where
do the other 80 whatever that number is
the other trill the other all the
trillium come from they come from all
the microorganisms that inhabit the
human body so we're used to thinking of
us being as a single microorganisms but
really we live in symbiosis with entire
ecosystems of other microorganisms and
those microorganisms are called our
microbiota and so how do we know that
they're there and we really only know
that they're a bit there because of
modern technology that allows us to find
them by DNA sequencing and so instead of
thinking about the hue
genome which you've probably heard
endlessly about and how important it is
we like to think about the genomes of
humans so we have a human genome but we
also Harbor all the genomes of all the
organisms that live within us and so the
human body harbors 10 to the 14th or a
hundred trillion microbial cells and ten
to the fifteenth viruses and I'm not
eating to talk about viruses at all the
number of microbial cells that inhabit
us out numbers the number of human cells
by an order of magnitude so that's a
factor of 10 this is called our
microbiota the genes of the organisms
encode are our microbiome we have a
bacteria we have some eukaryotes those
are those are some organisms with cells
we have viruses and we have one of these
rare domain members called an archaeon
most of these are in our intestinal
tract and this was a quote from 2012 the
literature characterizing the microbiota
or at least the bacterial parts of these
in disease is exploding so I the reason
I'm talking about this today is I think
this is one of the most exciting things
that's happened in medicine in the last
ten years and it's something that was
basically sitting with us the whole time
part of the reason we can find these is
the all the DNA sequencing efforts that
have happened many of these have been
funded by many of you who are taxpayers
and you pay your taxes in some small
portion of those taxes goes to the
National Institutes of Health and the
National Institutes of Health funds
these large projects like the human
microbiome projects that was founded to
a sequence the micro biomes of organisms
in a number of different body sites so
not only the intestine but 5 to 18
different sites there were a number of
different projects being run at the same
time as some of these were international
so that we could compare microorganisms
throughout the world so one of the sites
that was sequenced was the skin
microbiome because we live in symbiosis
with microorganisms on our skin and
these are some of the places that they
took these microorganisms from
which seems a pretty silly that they
would be all different but it turns out
that they are but today we're going to
talk about the human gut microbiome
because that's where feces come from and
it does vary within the gut and this is
a slide of showing you showing your
human digestive tract and so this is of
course your mouth and as you eat the
food goes to your stomach into your
small intestine and then into your large
intestine and eventually you excrete it
and I should have said at the very
beginning if any of you are squeamish
about human bodily functions this isn't
the right talk for you okay cuz this is
we're talking about and so the different
types of organisms that occur in these
different sites and your and your GI
tract are different and that's what
these pie graphs here in your gut which
is what we're going to be talking about
today the bacteria that are make it most
event seventy percent of it are things
called Firmicutes and bacteroides okay
so these are the normal inhabitants of
the gut your gut microbiome changes
during life when you're a baby you
acquire your microbiome from your mother
largely and as you move through life as
a young child and during pregnancy for
women and as an adult and then as an
elderly person your microbiome changes
with time and this quote argues that the
lumen of the distal gut is one of the
most densely populated ecosystems on the
planet there are also other organisms
that have very interesting microbiomes
one is this a squid here that uses a
microbiome to actually make light flies
and fish have different microbiomes we
actually use fish as a model system for
some of the human diseases mice have a
different microbiome than humans but
they all have a microbiome of some sort
okay so we're going to talk about what
happens when the gut microbiome gets
disturbed because what we are going to
talk about
is how you can use fecal transplant to
cure disease so how could the gut
microbiome get disturb so this is
supposed to be the lining of your
intestines if you have a healthy
microbiota you have these are intestinal
cells these little kilometer things here
and you have a coating of bacteria on
your intestinal cells and those bacteria
protect these intestinal cells and and
they do that by being there and by
making secreting certain substances that
allow the gut to be protected if your
microbiota are unhealthy okay and that's
shown on this side you see a breakdown
of this defense mechanism and fewer
microbial cells and some of the cool
things that happen is that these
microorganisms that line your gut not
only protect your gut by being there but
also stimulate these cells which are the
human cells to make certain compounds
that then protect your good so it's
really an interaction between the
microbial cells that we have in our gut
and the cells that in our human cells
that make it possible to protect us from
things like pathogens and the pathogen
that we're going to talk about today is
called Clostridium difficile otherwise
known as c diff infection can be deadly
it's a gram-positive spore-forming
bacterium it causes
antibiotic-associated diarrhea that
usually occurs in a medical facility
unfortunately it's now occurring more
and more not in a medical facility we
have antibiotics that work they're
becoming increasingly resistant and then
what happens and i'll show you slides of
this when people come off antibiotics
they relapse with infection you can
progress to really bad things like
pseudomembranous colitis and toxic
megacolon there are this many people a
year who get this that's a lot half a
million people a year gets c diff
infection it kills 29,000 people a year
and that was data from 2011 so that's a
lot so this is a problem but the weird
thing is
c diff is present normally in our guts
okay at a low level so the reason you
get infection for this is when that
balance in your gut goes wacky and you
have more see dip in it than you need
antibiotics can tamp it down when you go
off into biotics it comes back up so we
need a better solution so let me show
you some pictures this is seed if it's
an ugly-looking sucker this is what it
looks like and it causes this kind of
disruption in the border of the
intestines so this is a bad-looking
infection in the intestine ok so the
morbidity and mortality of c diff
infection i just told you about that
lots of people get sick that's what more
ability morbidity is mortality is lots
of people die and then following
antibiotic treatment these are the
antibiotics we use the relapsing nature
means that we need better therapies and
this is where fecal transplantation
comes in so fecal transplantation means
using feces a to cure c diff infection I
should caution you don't try this at
home okay this is not to try this at
home although apparently there are
people who do it's can often also called
in the literature FMT fecal microbiota
transplantation it's all the same thing
and so what is it so um c diff infection
can be treated by fecal transplantation
so you must obtain stool from a healthy
donor okay we'll talk about what that
means so you need stool from k where's
the word transplanting feces and what
the goal is is to replace this messed up
gut flora in people who are infected
with c diff with good gut flora from
somebody else who has a healthy gut and
they actually take the stool and as you
might imagine exact preparations very
they put it in a blender and then they
have to strain it you can freeze it okay
there are actually stool banks now for
at the beginning they were insisting
that people be treated through it and
they's
gastric tube and that's shown here these
are very uncomfortable and I would
probably do anything in the world to
avoid this it would I would hate it they
can also do it by colonoscopy and
there's and that's what's shown here
that's what's debated it needs to get to
your guts somehow remember your stomach
is an acidic environment you need to
kind of get it past your stomach the
stool and so that what they do is they
drop this tube into your duodenum your
small intestine and then they can put it
through the tube so the idea was is that
science hope to be able to you they're
using fecal transplants now but there's
some and I'll show you at the end
there's some effort to make a pill that
you could take that has bacteria that
would replace the ones that you're
missing okay so how long have we been
using a fecal transplantation we're
really just reviving an old therapy here
there's a 14th century Chinese handbook
of emergency medicine which is the
oldest recorded example of this in the
17th century there was an Italian an
anatomist who noted that animals 88
feces which isn't so surprising because
I can note that in my backyard with my
cocker spaniel almost every day but it
was used in veterinary practice for
rumination disorders which would
probably be in cows because they
ruminate so in 1958 eisenmann and
colleagues treated for patients with
this very bad disease with these fecal
enemas so this is stool that they got
from a healthy donor and then at that
time three-quarters the people would
have died and they saved their lives
okay so they wrote up a case report
about it and that was nineteen fifty
eight and if you look through the
literature on this or at least when I
look through it a few years ago there
this person whose name is um Thomas
Julius bharati who in Australia he's
treated over 500 patients and keeps
publishing on them his cure rate is
ninety-five percent which is pretty high
that that's like way higher than almost
anything that we do and but the problem
is is that all of these are case reports
none of these are controlled studies
none of these tell us what kind of still
we're supposed to be using none of these
tell us how of what what the dough
should be and so what where's the
literature looks like it would be really
positive in this regard in medicine we
don't go forward without very strict
guidelines and so in the New England
Journal a few years ago which is the
hallmark of kind of the journal everyone
helps to publish in for the first time
there was an article about curing c diff
infection with a fecal transplant and
this was carried out of the netherlands
and what they did was infuse donor feces
for recurrent a c diff infection and
this was the study design let me just
see if there's something else I'm
supposed to be telling you and they list
it's not totally important what the
study design the important thing is they
had a study design as opposed to all the
other doctors were just doing this kind
of ad hoc they had a study design it
where they compared people who got feces
to people who didn't get feces and how
well did they do this is very important
in medicine it was not double blinded
which means that people knew if they
were getting feces I guess that would
have been pretty obvious okay so that
that is always a problem when you're
doing a medical study but in this case
it couldn't be avoided and it was
interesting to note that they put some
thought into deciding what we should
screen the donor feces for because you
don't want to give someone feces and
make them worse and so we screen they
screen them for things like parasites of
course for the thing that that you're
trying to cure and then the blood for
other communica communicable diseases
and this is one of the big discussions
do we do we what do we screen for and
when is enough and I think the answer is
we don't really know yet but they screen
for many things so they gave these to
people and did it work it worked great
and this is what they found they
actually stopped the study because they
thought it was unethical to proceed and
not to treat everyone with fecal
transplantation so so it works and let
me show you what I mean by that this is
an easy graph to read these are the
percentage of people
without relapse you can see the people
who got donor feces did great they had
really high cure rates if they only got
one they were cured eighty-one percent
of the time and if they got overall a
feces they were cured ninety-four
percent of the time and since this is a
study that compared it to antibiotics
alone where they only had a thirty-one
percent curate and antibiotics with
washing out your bowel where they had a
lower curate so now is the first time a
study has ever been done that shows that
fecal transplantation works they so the
question you might ask is why does it
work what's what is happening is they
did a little bit of work on that the
working hypothesis was is that when you
gave people a fecal transplant that they
would then reconstitute a new gut
microbiota that was the working
hypothesis and that turned out to be
true here we have a graph that that's
just a way of looking at the diversity
of microbiota a before and after fecal
transplantation this is the diversity of
the microbiota in the fecal donors this
was the poor diversity in the patients
before they got the transplant and this
was the diversity after so you can see
that it's working to cure disease by
restoring the gut microbiota but there
are some issues okay so the question is
how do we what is the optimal protocol
nobody knows do we need to wash out the
gut how much do you give somebody how
much is enough is a little bit enough
could you get away with freezing a
little bit and just swallowing that or
do you have to do this big procedure in
the hospital and then again do you want
to do an invasive procedure where tubes
and all kinds of anesthesia is involved
is there a simpler thing we can do and
those are some of the things that we
don't know about there were some letters
to the editor about these studies
pointing out the problems with them so
even though it sounds like it was a
really great thing the conversations
that we have about new cures and
medicine
always have are always on going because
we're always trying to do the best thing
and some people wrote in and said that
they shouldn't have discontinued the
study because no one was dying which
seems like kind of a high bar but there
you go here they complained that we need
a better well-designed clinical trials
which may or may not be possible and it
and and this person thinks that they
didn't really screen enough for diseases
in the donor feces that they failed to
screen for tuberculosis yep they did and
there could be another 20 diseases and
one of them could be Zika virus for
example that you might want to screen
for so so we're not we're not there yet
and totally understand again there are
other diseases that people want to treat
with fecal transplantation this is just
a small list of them the one I talked
about is c diff infection but irritable
bowel syndrome chronic constipation a
disease called ulcerative colitis and a
related disease called Crohn's disease
there are all trials on going to use
fecal transplantation to treat these
diseases and then there are a number of
other diseases that have nothing to do
with the gut where there may be some
link between your gut microbiota and
these diseases some of these don't make
a huge amount of sense because some of
them are autoimmune but there is good
evidence or increasingly good evidence
that it might be true so there are a lot
of other kinds of studies going on so um
so how does this sit with people it
doesnt sit very well with the government
who the FDA is trying to regulate the
use of drugs and how do you regulate a
stool donation for fecal transplantation
it's not a drug it hasn't passed the
stringent requirements this is a an
argument that that are arguing that
perhaps there are many risks that we
don't know about already and so the FDA
has said that physicians who perform
this need special permission to do it
but then they later said that although
they need special permission to do it
they're going to ignore whether or not
they have it okay so they're not sure
exactly what to do there is an
investigator at MIT who has argued that
fecal transplantation should be in the
constant context is tissue donation and
not as a drug which puts it in a
different regulatory pocket and I don't
know what it's going to be eventually so
so what we really need is not to do
fecal transplantation since we don't
know what bacteria and the feces no one
standardizes that we don't know how much
to give we can't we can't check all the
diseases that people have who are
donating the feces so what we really
need is a pill that has the right
composition of bacteria in them and so
there are a number of people trying to
do this and this is just one example and
this was in mice so as far as I know it
hasn't been done in humans yet and so
what they did was they restored a c diff
infection in mice by giving them a pill
of bacteria i'll show you some graphs
how that works so these bacteria c diff
can infect mice and this here is just a
count of how how much bacteria the mice
are excreting in their intestines so can
you imagine the graduate student who has
to had to do these experiments they had
to go around and collect all the mouse
feces and calculate how much seed if
they had in there in there in there
pellets but so here's measuring seed if
the mice have a high level of c diff
infection when they're treated with
antibiotics it goes down when they take
them off antibiotics it goes up again
when they cheat with amanda biotics it
goes down okay and that's just what
happens in humans that's why we need a
better therapies so what they did was
they took feces in mice from from a
normal Mouse and we're able to show that
fecal transplantation in mice will cure
c diff as it does in humans
they this also not only restructures the
mice to have them but then keeps them
from passing it on to other mice and
that's what what is shown here the
important thing is is that um they made
a mix at the guests at what the bacteria
might be that are repopulating the mouse
guts and they made three different mixes
of bacteria they called them a B and C
and then they tested them because now
they have a model that they can test
these on these these therapies on and
you can see here that one worked the
green one worked mix be worked it cured
the mice again we're counting how much
bacterium they have in their feces some
graduate student is counting how much
bacteria they have in their feces one
work because it went down and two didn't
so you may ask yourself as I did what is
in that mix be what are the bacteria in
there that are doing this okay what's
really cool is and they call it
bacterial therapy mix be it's all the
green guys so it's this one this one
this one this one this one this one they
put them all together they only work all
together so it's really a question of
not having the right one bacteria it's
really a question of having the right
ecosystem in your gut one other
interesting thing is some of these are
brand new species so that's what this SP
no means after them they're brand new
ones okay so this gave us hope that we
can maybe make a pill that we can treat
people with so how does this work the
the way it works and this is a picture
of how we think it might work is um this
is how well how your gut is normally
living happily remember these are the
kilometer cells of your intestinal
epithelium these are the bacteria living
happily above if you take antibiotics
you can get a transient dysbiosis which
is a fancy word for saying it screws up
your gut and
does every time you take antibiotics but
normally you can just go back to normal
when you get off antibiotics in the rare
case that you're in the hospital you
might end up with a c difficile
inspection and then you infection and
then you get a really bad a disruption
in your gut and that makes these ugly
little red cells and lack of your lack
of the protective mechanisms that
usually keep your gut safe you can be
treated by back to your therapy
restoring a happier gut and that
restores you to the homeostasis then you
were you had in the first place so
that's how they think it's working so
one of the other things that people are
trying and again like me everyone likes
to use ponds on the word poop okay so
this is a a stool substitute transplant
therapy for eradication of c diff
infection otherwise known as
repopulating the gut which is course is
a play on the word repopulating the gut
and the idea is they made something they
call synthetic stool which means that
they took healthy donor stool and took
some bacteria out of it and gave it to
two patients only two so that's a
problem when you only do two it's not
enough but they did too but these are
and these are people who are stricken
with this very difficult infection and
their diary resolved within 72 hours and
didn't recur for up to six months even
though they were getting antibiotics for
other reasons and I'll show you their
clinical course it's a complicated slide
the only thing you need to look at is um
these are the weeks that they followed
this is a clinical course of the two
patients this is one patient this is the
second patient this is the number of
weeks they were followed they got a lot
of antibiotics they were they were
referred to the repopulate study they
got the synthetic stool and they were
symptom-free for the weeks that they
that they were followed and the same
with a second one so they view this as a
success
there are a number of companies that
have been started to to to make those
magic pills that will be able to take
that instead of having to be
administered fecal transplants and one
of them is this company called re
biotics which says that they are making
microbiota restoration therapy or
otherwise abbreviated s-m-r-t they have
a great website that's full of them
advertisements basically harnessing the
power of the microbiome to treat
challenging diseases they're focusing on
c diff infection I told you all sort of
colitis which is an infection of your
large bowel and then they're also
working on treating multi multi
drug-resistant infections which can
sometimes happen in the hospital and so
they've have some of these drugs that
they've come up with it very early
clinical trials still not a certain
what's going to come of them and they're
not the only company who's interested in
it so you may at the beginning I told
you that aside from fecal
transplantation we there's been an
exploding literature about how important
the gut microbiome is and I'll just give
you a couple other examples this is one
of my favorite papers there's a disease
that occurs in Africa called kwashiorkor
I was taught a medical school that it
was a disease of protein malnutrition
Jeff Gordon who actually whose father
Martin Gordon lives in New Haven he's at
University of Washington he did really
interesting Studies on twins in Malawi
so they're twins where one person has
quashed your core or this protein
malnutrition disease and the other one
doesn't and the question is why because
they were eating the same things it
turns out they have totally different
gut microbiomes and it was the gut
microbiota that was contributing to this
human protein malnutrition disease that
we haven't known how to cure since we
first described it which was a long time
ago and what he then went on to do was
to do studies in mice
where he showed that he could then cure
the mice who had kwashiorkor by giving
them back the right gut microbiome so to
me this is a hugely interesting thing it
suggests that a gut microbiome plays
into diseases of malnutrition and
poverty and there are a couple other
really intriguing things some of these I
think are really wild there's an idea
that perhaps the gut microbiome like
microbiota contributes to cancer okay
and maybe in order to be treated with
these toxic cancer drugs and for that
treatment to be successful you need an
appropriate us ecosystem in your gut and
then and that's true also with this
paper so all that is totally new we
don't know yet how it's going to play
out in the end but it's kind of the
brain brave new world of medicine so I
just made one summary and I'm happy to
take any questions summary of what I
told you today is that they're going to
be a whole bunch of new therapies that
boost our microbiota in our gut that
will eventually cure disease so I'm
happy to take any questions yep
so I was asked a really good question
about with taking a probiotic help or in
other words if you have c diff infection
why isn't a probiotic enough so so for
those of you who may not know what a
probiotic is a probiotic are these
bacteria you can buy in pills for
example at whole foods I have some of my
fridge right now those are usually
lactobacillus they were there one kind
of bacteria their kind of bacteria that
lives in yogurt see if you eat a lot of
yogurt you're getting these they're not
enough and they're not diverse enough to
repopulate a gut that's that's infected
by a really bad bacterium but but it's
the same idea is c diff infection
hereditary no it's acquired and it's
usually acquired in the hospital when
when you are in the hospital for another
reason in fact i had my appendix out
about five years ago and i knew the
surgeons could take my appendix out
because in fact it's an interns case but
I worried that the two days I spent in
the hospital I might get something else
so I want to get out of there as fast as
I could other questions uh-huh
so the question I'll repeat the question
is is you know is medicine too
restrictive and our are we being held
back by the regulations that we have on
new cures like this fecal
transplantation thing so it was
interesting for me to watch this so I
gave this talk originally two years ago
and I went back and looked at the
literature since then and one of the
things I saw was that in the current
literature it says that this used to be
considered a fringe treatment and it's
now made the medical mainstream and I
think it's a good example of how
pressure I think doctors aren't stupid
and when they see a when they see
something that works they're going to go
for it i think that we're cautious for a
reason with our regulations because many
bad things have happened to people so it
needs to be a balance uh-huh yeah so
that's one of the reasons they drop
these NG tube the nasogastric tubes and
they give them back to you by
colonoscopy colonoscopy because they're
worried about the stomach acid they do
or enough of them do to populate to
populate the gut uh-huh
so I don't know I think it seems to be
small biotech companies that are working
on making these formulations and not the
big drug companies and usually what
happens at least for me watching them
not that I have no vested interest in
any of the stuff I own no companies the
what usually happens with the small
biotech when they get to a certain
productivity they get bought by the
large companies but for my kind of
snooping around the internet it seems to
be that the small companies that are
taking the risks I think it's a huge
market and I think it's a little it's
going to be a little tricky to define
what we really need but i think it's i
think it's great i think it's the future
uh-huh
that's a good question so so I I'm
thinking that they just these were
bacteria that could be cultured and so
they just cultured them and then put
them together in different mixes it
brings up a very important point though
that I failed to say and that was that
not all the bacteria that live on our
guts we can culture and we can we can we
know they're there because we can
sequence them but we may not have the
right condition to culture them but I
think that's a good point we could be
missing something that might be useful
mm-hmm how about other organs what do
you mean how about other organs yes they
have and I actually do a paper with my
medical students on acne and a vitamin
b12 and the importance of a particular
micro organisms on the face and how that
microorganism use uses b12 so there are
other examples of where the wrong set of
microorganisms can cause problems for us
but I think we're just at the tip of the
iceberg or with these things I I just
think this is so cool that that we live
in symbiosis symbiosis with these
trillions of organisms and not only to
do we benefit from them but they
couldn't live without us either I just
think it's totally cool
hi cat so the studies that have been
done don't can't answer that but there
is argument among physicians about
whether a colonoscopy works better than
an amazing ass tricked tube so a
colonoscopy is less invasive perhaps
than a nasogastric tube and maybe that
would be enough but then some people say
no so and nobody knows the answer
because we haven't done enough of them
yes a six-year-old who thinks it
colonoscopies pretty invasive as it is
so how varied are microbiomes from
person to person or the person in from
region to region and follow you think
will start to you know if our annual
physical get our microbiome pattern and
it will know whether it's a good shape
or bad shape and yeah so um so how I
don't know the answer that question
because I'm not sure okay so curso
professors elmast I'm how variable our
microbiome so of all the people in the
room is everybody different or everybody
the same I don't know the answer that
and I think we don't know the answer
that because we haven't it's expensive
to do it so we don't we don't know it's
kind of like a personalized medicine
question you know is but my guess would
be that we have a lot of similarities
but some very important differences
right just like just like being what
being people is the but I do think I do
think that as the price comes down for
DNA sequencing that that it'll be an
important part of our of our annual
physical I've also heard that Jo
Handelsman who is our representative at
the White House now at my colleague and
one of the department's at Yale has been
trying to get President Obama to have
his microbiome sequence and so far Steph
re hasn't yielded to the pressure
2 seed if so the question is are there
other symptoms to having your microbiome
microbiota out of whack and your gut so
one of the things that you know comes to
mind it was on that list is this thing
called irritable bowel syndrome which is
kind of an ill-defined thing which may
or may not be a disease people who
suffer from that tend to have diarrhea
alternated by constipation and a lot of
kind of what's the right word Thank You
bloating uncle discomfort in the gut and
that could be a microbiota out of whack
and that's one of the things that people
hope to be able to make a pill for
that's what often probiotics are
marketed for huh I didn't I'm not
advocating anything like that and that's
and I hope that nobody that sounds
really awful and wait let me just just
say what an enema is for people that's
when you put something up up your rear
end okay let me tell to the kids it
doesn't go very far okay so it doesn't
work very well okay that's why you need
a colonoscopy to to really put these
things in if you're trying to cure c
diff infection so so i don't know i
think the evidence so far is is that
when you take antibiotics and and after
you go off them you restore your gut
microbiota you store them by eating
normally so so i don't think i would go
crazy worrying about that i think that
these people would see diff infection or
at risk for death and it's a horrible
thing when you have it and then it
happens a lot of times with people who
are immune compromised to have cancer so
they have many other things to worry
about and so it's really a kind of a
cure for something that that we really
had no cure for
yep yep so what I was reading just a
couple days ago was is that they now do
these things where they um they'll take
a stool donor that's been checked out
for various diseases which we could
argue about which they are and they
freeze them into like little pills they
freeze the stool in little pills and
they can give 15 to someone and
reconstitute the gut 15 is a lot of
pills okay plus you're swallowing stool
okay so that's why i'd much rather
swallow a gelatin encapsulated mixture
of sterile bacteria that I know what's
in there because who knows what's in the
school thing
and how they eat you mean yeah so um one
of the things I didn't talk about was
what one of the things that first things
that Jeff Gordon did was look at abby's
people versus not obese people and he
was able to show that obese people had a
different gut microbiota than not obese
people and at least in mice if you then
take the gut microbiota from the thin
mice and give it to the fat mice you can
make them thin which begs the question
of what is cause and effect so so I
don't think we totally know the answer
to this whole thing yet it's not just
the food there's there's something else
and I don't think we know but again I
think it's we're at the tip of the
iceberg are beginning to understand this
uh-huh no sorry there's there's someone
in the back sorry go ahead no its you go
ahead can you eat other foods that have
bacteria in them you mean not just
yogurt so yogurt is the one that we
expect to have live cultures in them if
you read the yogurt box some of them
will say live cultures and it'll say
what they are so i hope all of you go
home and read your yogurt boxes and see
if see if they have left cultures in
them most of the other foods we eat
except for fermented foods like sour
kraut sauerkraut has probably has
bacteria in it but most the time we
don't eat food where we've deliberately
put bacteria in them but there's
bacteria on everything right so yes I
think there probably is bacteria and
other foods we eat we just don't kind of
know what they are and then you ask a
question
so the question was with GMO foods be
different than non GMO foods for how
they affect the gut and the short answer
is that I don't think we know the GMO
foods are usually a single change in a
gene so I would think probably not but
the answer is we don't know uh-huh just
a year and work with work for what could
you use so if you had urinary tract
infections because you cure them by
giving them year and no no actually I
don't think so but but let me think
about this for a minute
so no because well I think we do I don't
know but I would imagine that we do have
some kind of microbiota in our bladders
well the bladder is supposed to be
sterile so it must be in the urinary
tract coming coming out and I don't
think there you go there's something to
study I don't think Sara's another
question I thought go ahead well that's
an interesting idea I think it's easier
just to take a pill of ones that someone
else is defined like you would take a
pill for I don't know your blood
pressure or something else but but
that's in it that's a little be another
approach I think it's harder any other
questions I'm happy to talk to anybody
who wants to talk to me afterwards thank
you